he's a speedy guy leads the league in
stolen base he's eighth in the league
with 18 doubles so
2-2 and a little chopper slowly toward
third charging colbertson with the bare
hand to throw in time and they just get
merryfield for out number one
field runs really well
and on that kind of a swinging bunt you
get a little bit of a good head start as
a right-hand hitter
dunning's first pitch and o'hearn sends
it down the left field line white into
that corner and he makes the catch right
before banging into the wall nice play
by eli white one away
the key is to get there as quickly as
you can and when you get there to make
that play he knows he's going to hit the
wall right now look at the concentration
in his eyes as he catches it bracing
himself running into the wall that's a
beautiful play
two runs nine hits on sunday but both
runs
and seven of the nine hits
came after two outs and nobody on base
there's a nice play at third by alberto
he's gonna have to hurry and it is in
time two third baseman tonight in
arlington are putting on a clinic
that's well hit right center field
slicing away from garcia and that's a
dive and a miss
the royals first hit will be an rbi
triple as merrifield drives in nikki
lopez and the royals lead one nothing in
the third dane dunning got tired of him
fouling balls off he goes all right i'm
just gonna challenge you and wood said
okay that little motion you were talking
about staying inside the ball that's
exactly what he did
oh
has an rbi and now a really good
defensive play going up the middle
against isaiah connor philippa oh that
was lovely and how about both teams
rolling out some great d this is a
two-step and a dive actually three steps
got to his feet looked like a
fantastic play there way to help mike
miner out with an out
good strong throw
defense has been very strong
i said in the open since june 4th
thankfully there was a man on first and
they weren't in that kind of shift
that joey hit into the first time though
so now
an even better opportunity that one
almost gets to right field merit field
grabbed it but he throws it into the
camera well perfect
garcia scores
gallow to third
and on the error abanez will walk to
second base
so the rangers are on the board and
we're tied at one merrifield catches the
ball as it's by him and then tries to
make a spectacular play didn't have any
chance at first base should have held on
to the ball and he knows that
would have been the bases loaded nobody
out anyway
as it was he threw the ball away and
everybody moved up the base and garcia
scored nate lowe at the plate
and he lines this one out into left
field late start and then that one gets
past dozier
gallows in here
comes low heading to third and he'll be
in there with a two run triple
it's three to one rangers hey talk about
the lead off walks and that got the
rangers started that was an extremely
hard hit line drive by nate lowe and it
just ate up hunter dozier in left field
he thinks it's a routine base hit then
he realizes how hard it was hit how well
it's carrying toward him and said well
maybe i do have a chance but he decided
too late
and it bounced in front of him and went
right by him for a triple i'm grounded
out in the second inning infield remains
in
and this ball hit out into left field
that's a base hit it'll get low to the
plate and it makes it 4-1 rangers
jonah's been swinging the good bat
lately came into the game in his last
six games seven for 18. he's eight for
20 now that's a 400 average in his last
20 at that picks up an rbi to go along
with those things
down and away
well it was down and away but it's
lifted high in the air and deep out to
right center and
garcia
whoa
sneaking right up against the wall to
catch that one like a wide receiver oh
what a finish to the inning
with a couple of base runners nobody out
and solac coming up
this ball just over second base that's a
base hit
in the score ebonyes
low stops at second
solak delivers an rbi single
miner's changeup has had significant
movement away from the right-hand hitter
but it stayed up if it's down it's a
different story but when it stayed up it
at least allowed nick to get the bat on
the ball and bloop it over second pick
up another run
stroked over third and that's trouble
all the way down into the corner low
will score easily solo stopped at third
on the double by heim
but the rangers have added two runs in
the inning
and it's six to two they're teeing off
right now mike just doesn't have a pitch
he can get him out with
jonah got a pitch on the inside part of
the plate put a perfect swing on it
hit it right off the barrel pulled it
right down the line two hits for him in
the game tonight
seven for his last 18 coming into the
game two for three in this game picks up
an rbi four straight hits for the
rangers
and nobody out
oh two
when he shoots that one to the gap
right center field that'll bring home a
pair culverson hustling for two and he's
in there with a two-run double and it's
an 8-2 rangers lead and rangers are
hitting pitches that are pretty good
although i will say this that good
movement on it it's not a strike it's
off the plate miner had a rough one
tonight he's done carlos hernandez
coming on two from hernandez
and that one in the air
out to right field solaire edges back to
make the catch culverson tags he'll
score
so it's a sack fly for el bombie
that's to the rangers late it's now 9-2
michael a taylor is over three and
here's manager chris woodward did you
read his lips i'm not going to take you
out
that's a line drive into left center
field and
michael a taylor is going to pick up a
couple of rbis so solaire dozier and
taylor get base hits with two down
and it's 9-4 in the ninth well he's
going to take him out now and spencer
patton is in the pitch nice job so far
for spencer patton this will be his
ninth game
and he strikes out swinging patton slams
the door in the ninth inning and the
rangers finish off a 9-4 beating of
kansas city
great
start to the series
good slider to end it nice job by
spencer patton coming in
making sure that this game doesn't get
close came in with one thing in mind get
that one out face one hitter